I used my SketchUp model for this wooden
combination lock model and turned it
into a laser cut version using the
flight of ideas plugin to make the SVG
files which I found tricky to use so
this video explains how I used it this
wooden combination lock uses a few
pieces of wood that are thicker than a
laser cutter can cut so the first thing
I had to do is to modify the design and
here is the laser cut version of the
combination lock these pieces are built
out of multiple layers and I also add
add a little bit of interlocking of the
layers because that sort of thing is
relatively easy to do with a laser
cutter and the next step was to take all
of these individual pieces like this
piece here and arranged them all in a
flat plane for laser
cutting which I've done here and I'm
going to use the flight of ideas plugin
to export these to SVG files and what I
found with the flight of ideas plugins
it tends to rearrange parts that are not
in some ways connected together so what
I could do is to just draw little line
segments between them but uh that is
rather
counterproductive so it's much better to
actually have the parts all touching
each other and so I still need to do
some rearranging for these
parts now to export these with the
flight of ideas Plus plugin I need to
select the surfaces that I want to
export and with all of these pieces
being individual objects the only way I
can select the surface is to open the
object and uh that's no good for
selecting all of these surfaces all at
once so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take all this stuff and make a
copy of it by just doing a control
drag and now zooming in on this stuff
here I'm going to right click on it and
select
explode and that breaks up all of these
objects so that I can now select
surfaces on all of these together and so
I could try to select like this but I
can use a trick to get these all
together which is to look at him from
the top using parallel
projection and I need to get this just
right and now I'll just select like this
through the object
itself and I have all the front surfaces
selected
and none of the
back and now ideally I would just right
click on here and select export to SVG
file but if I do
this it seems like it did something but
it's not the final confirmation dialogue
isn't there and it's just created an
empty file I find this plug-in is
somewhat
flaky so what I do with this sort of
thing is and now I just do copy
and I'll start a new CAD
model and now I'll paste what I've
got and let's do this again export to
SVG file and save now it's important
that the file ends with that
SVG and there we go and this is the file
I just created and I'll open that up in
Google Chrome which displays the SVG
file but you'll notice I have this
circle and and this little rectangle
that did not appear to be where they're
supposed to be this circle was supposed
to be here and the reason for that is
going back in here this circle isn't
touching so I'll just take that Circle
and I'll drag it so now it touches and I
can verify that it touches by just
triple clicking and that selects
everything and the problem with this
little rectangle this also ended up in
the wrong place and this took me quite a
while to figure out but the problem with
this rectangle is you'll notice there's
a gap
here this little rectangle is not co-
planer with everything
else so I'm going to fix that by just
taking this line here and I will just
drag that to make it
Cooper and I need to refresh the line in
here so that it's not
hidden and let's export everything again
select
everything export to SVG
file got the confirmation so we know it
works and open this file
again and now I have this rectangle in
the right place and this circle right
here and that is now ready to send off
to the laser cutting company but I've
already sent this off a previous version
this is the updated version it has all
the mistakes that I found when
assembling this thing fixed